hey crazies cosmic time is measured in
billions of years that's thousands of
millions what what what when we hear
words like million or billion all we
really hear is big so let's get a better
perspective with a different unit of
time the Galactic year this episode was
made possible by generous supporters on
patreon
what's a galactic year the time it takes
the Sun to orbit the galaxy
it's about 230 million years can we just
make up a unit like that yeah all units
are made up alright let's start with
some basics any measurement has two
required parts a number and a unit you
need both or it's not a measurement and
don't give me any of that the unit is
implied nonsense anyway get a
measurement is whatever a measurement is
the distance between the Sun and the
earth is an average of about 93 million
miles miles is the unit and 93 million
is the number but it doesn't matter what
number and unit we assign to this
distance I could just as easily say it's
a hundred and fifty million kilometers
or 150 Giga meters none of that actually
changes the distance between the Earth
and the Sun the point is the unit choice
is up to us so we might as well choose
one that's convenient since the
measurement is whatever it is using a
larger unit means we get a smaller
number so let's make the unit here
really big we can call this distance one
astronomical unit or au we can just do
that oh yeah for sure
all units are made up calling the
Earth's Sun distance one au is
convenient for distances within our
solar system Mars is one point five
eight u from the Sun Jupiter five point
two au Neptune 30 au check out this
video if you want to learn more about
the scale of the solar system okay we
just chose a convenient unit for
distance we can do the same with time
there are a lot of different units for
time
the standard base unit is seconds but
that's way too small for measuring
cosmic time we've also got minutes hours
days months and even years but they're
still not big enough
remember cosmic time is measured in
thousands of millions of years a million
years are what we call a mega year is
still a little too small some of our
numbers will be uncomfortably large a
billion years or what we call a Giga
year has the opposite problem some of
our numbers will end up a little too
small we need a unit that's in between
the two and that's where the Galactic
Year comes in the time it takes for the
earth to travel around the Sun once is
defined as one year for the rest of the
video we'll call that one earth year the
time it takes for the Sun to travel
around the galaxy once is about 230
million earth years we'll call that one
galactic year it's like a sweet spot
between a million and a billion it's
exactly what we need the beginning of
the known universe occurred 13.8 billion
earth years ago which is equivalent to
60 galactic years ago that's it that's
the number not 60 million not 60,000
just 60 is that cool or what we've made
our unit just the right size so that our
numbers are ordinary everyday numbers so
let's see what happens with the rest of
cosmic time galaxies begin to form about
two galactic years after the Big Bang
that's about 58 galactic years ago our
own Sun is a third-generation star so it
didn't form for another 36.3 galactic
years about 21.7 galactic years ago the
earth formed shortly after about 20
galactic years ago so something can
happen pretty quickly no I don't think
you can keep using years okay what will
subdivide it then fine if we're calling
this a year then we could easily divide
it the same way we divide a normal earth
here months vary a bit too much so we'll
skip those and jump right two days let's
say there are 365 galactic days
in a galactic year and 24 galactic hours
in a galactic day and 60 galactic
minutes in a galactic hour and so on
that way we can maintain the same
perspective we had with galactic years
it might have only taken two galactic
years for galaxies to form but it only
took about 14 galactic hours for the
universe to go transparent that's how
early the cosmic microwave background
was released way before galaxies the
universe was dark for a long time can we
do geologic time too sure why not the
earth formed 20 galactic years ago the
moon formed about a hundred and sixty
galactic days later so not long after
the earth spent a few galactic years
being continuously bombarded with space
rocks around fifteen galactic years ago
that bombardment slowed just enough for
life to form seriously life formed the
moment it was possible by 14 galactic
years ago photosynthesis had evolved in
cyanobacteria by 11 galactic years ago
some living cells had formed a cell
nucleus at this point earth still only
has single-celled life multicellular
organisms don't appear until three
galactic years ago apparently that was a
rough transition after that though life
got pretty good at this whole evolution
thing by two galactic years ago there
were plants on land by one-and-a-half
galactic years ago there were animals on
land the dinosaurs went extinct less
than a galactic year ago about a hundred
and three galactic days ago modern
humans evolved about 7.5 galactic hours
ago human civilization began just 27
galactic minutes ago and a single human
life is only about 12 galactic seconds
long we are such a tiny fraction of
cosmic time and that's only the time
that's happened so far for galactic
years from now the Sun will be so hot
that the Earth's oceans will boil away
in about 22 galactic years the Sun will
expand into a red giant in Gulf
the earth any record we ever existed
here will be erased from the universe
that got depressing real fast as you can
see though galactic years is an
extremely convenient unit for cosmic
time for quicker jumps we can easily
divide it up into smaller units to get
bigger numbers
what galactic years works quite well
most of the time and it gives us a
really good perspective on cosmic and
geologic timescales
it keeps the numbers for all these
events as ordinary everyday numbers
their numbers we have a good handle on
so hopefully that helps with your
perspective a little bit if you have any
questions please ask in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
why did you only use straight paths for
the photon if all paths are possible
what about the curved ones okay yes
curved paths are possible it's just that
they're difficult to animate especially
with those phaser arrows I only needed a
few paths to make my points so I chose
the easy ones anyway thanks for watching